CORY: Hello everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I'm joined in studio today by
Bill Reichert, an entrepreneur,
founder and MD of the
Garage Technology Fund.
How are you?
BILL REICHERT: Thank you.
Doing great.
CORY: So tell us a little
bit about Garage Fund.
And we were talking
a little bit before,
and how that's been an
entrepreneurial endeavor on DC.
BILL REICHERT: Yeah.
So as I was saying, I
spent most of my career
as an entrepreneur, starting
up mainly software companies.
And then in 1998 I got
together with Guy Kawasaki
and a few other people to try
to reinvent the venture space.
And so we started Garage
Technology Ventures
to be a new kind of
venture capital firm.
And so the big idea was to have
the broadest global outreach
of any venture capital firm.
So from day one, our big idea
was that the next big thing
is not really about technology.
It's about entrepreneurship.
And so what we wanted
to do was to tap
every brilliant
entrepreneur we could find,
wherever they were on the
globe, and then bring them
in to the venture ecosystem,
fund them along the way,
and take a piece of
equity as part of that.
So we did companies from all
over the world and from nearby,
out of Stanford, like companies
like Pandora on the one hand,
and then a company out
of Finland called u-NAV,
which did a chip.
So we've been all over the
place starting up companies.
So that was the big idea
for Garage when we started.
Fast forward.
It's now 2015.
It's a wildly different world.
And we were right,
it turned out,
that entrepreneurship
has gone global.
And so we've decided to partner
with the group here called
F50, to create the
F50 Garage Venture
Fund, to take advantage of all
of energy that's going on here.
So we've got-- for
those of you who
are listening-- we've got
thousands of entrepreneurs
here, meeting and greeting
one another across I
think 100 different
pavilions, with all sorts
of new technologies, from space
technology to software apps
to 3D manufacturing,
to you name it.
So that's what I love is finding
these brilliant, emerging
entrepreneurs, figuring out a
way to help them be successful,
and then investing in the
best of them along the way.
CORY: So that's awesome.
And you did turn out to be
really prophetic, it seems.
If you look around this room--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORY: So do you
have any thoughts
as to why that happened?
Like, why the kind of
rise of entrepreneurialism
across the globe?
BILL REICHERT: Yeah, so
the great thing that's
happened over this
last 15 years is
that through the combination
of the internet and mobile,
and then wireless technology,
and then standardization
of technologies, you can have
two graduate students in Mumbai
hack together an app
over the weekend,
launch it Monday, and reach
2 and 1/2 billion people all
over the planet.
So good news, bad news,
if you're an entrepreneur.
It used to be if you were a
Silicon Valley entrepreneur,
all you had to worry about
were the other Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs.
Now you've got to worry about
everybody across the planet.
So because of
these technologies,
it's been easier than
ever to start a company.
But the thing not too
many people talk about
is that it has never been harder
to build a successful company.
So it's this crazy dichotomy
if you're an entrepreneur.
It's easy to get started,
but it's really hard
to be the winner.
CORY: So that's
interesting, because we
do see a lot of
opportunity, I guess,
of what you'd call top of
the funnel entrepreneurship.
It's been harder to move through
to what you might call a scale
stage company.
And so do you see
Garage, at some point,
spending some time
working on that?
As you saw that wave coming?
BILL REICHERT: Well, absolutely.
At the end of the day, what
we're most interested in
is finding the
best entrepreneurs
and then investing in
them through content,
through events, through
online materials,
through speaking and presenting.
We want to give back to
the entrepreneur community
to help them be most successful.
Now everybody can
go a different path.
And one of the important things
that entrepreneurs should know
is that the only
way to be successful
is not through venture capital.
That was a double negative.
But in any case,
there are plenty
of ways to be successful
without having
to bang your head against the
venture capital brick wall.
And I'm one of the first
to encourage entrepreneurs,
if you can fund your company
through revenues, God bless.
Go do it.
But sometimes you
need outside help.
You need investors.
And so the big idea behind
the F50 Garage Venture Fund
is to build this network
of investors, a larger
community of investors,
who are looking
for these high performing
startup companies,
co-invest together, and help
those companies be successful.
So unlike a typical venture
fund, which all they've got
is their own fund, the idea
behind the F50 Garage Fund
is to bring a
network of investors
together around these companies
and give entrepreneurs
access to that larger
network, so it's not just us.
So that gives entrepreneurs
a lot more choices,
and a lot more potential
to be successful.
CORY: And do you find
this analogous at all
to some of the online
investing platforms?
BILL REICHERT: Yeah.
The idea of
syndicating is not new.
The idea of online is not new.
The big idea with F50 is rather
than focusing at the very, very
early stage crowdfunding
types of companies,
we're sitting sort
of at the next level.
So what we're focused
are the graduates
of the incubators and
accelerators of the Angel Lists
and the other
crowdfunding, Kickstarters.
So we want to take
those graduates
and help them get
to the next level.
So our network is
institutional investors
that are writing bigger
checks than just Angels.
We also have a lot
of Angels, as well as
other traditional venture
capital and corporate venture
capital partners in the model.
So we see ourselves
as being part
of the continuum of the
ecosystem for entrepreneurs.
CORY: So how does
that process work
if I'm an entrepreneur looking
to get found in the community.
How would that work?
BILL REICHERT: So
that's a great question.
So the first thing
you do is you plug in.
And the first place you
plug in is at F50.io.
So go to F50.io.
If you're an entrepreneur,
you can register
and you can put together your
profile on the F50.io site.
And then you can use that to
tap into a network of investors,
other entrepreneurs,
and other resources
to help you grow your company.
So the intent is that
the online platform
helps you connect, network, and
learn, but also offline events.
Real time face to face
events are critical.
CORY: So obviously
with the global reach
that you guys have, you're
going to see a lot of deal flow.
So what is the advice you could
give to entrepreneurs who are
looking to reach out to you?
BILL REICHERT: Thank you.
Thank you.
So one thing I
spend a lot of time
trying to help
entrepreneurs get better at
is being more effective at
articulating their value
proposition.
So most entrepreneurs,
most developers,
they love to talk
about their product.
I was there too.
I thought my product was so
beautiful, it was so gorgeous,
it was so sexy, it was so cool.
And we love talking
about our products.
But at the end of
the day, customers
want to know what value
you create for them.
Investors want to know, what
is your unique and compelling
value proposition?
So entrepreneurs,
please, when you're
talking to investors, when
you're talking to customers,
when you're talking
about your company,
don't get wrapped
up in the product.
Three tricks to
being successful--
be clear, be compelling,
and be credible.
So be really clear what it
is you're doing and for whom.
Be compelling.
Make sure it's clear what
the value is that you create.
What's your compelling
benefit for your customers?
It can't just be
a little better,
it's got to be a lot better.
It's got to be insanely
better if you're going
to get people to pay attention.
And then lastly, be credible.
Because the problem
is, everybody lies.
We all lie.
So that's OK.
But to differentiate yourself
from all the other liars,
it's really helpful if you can
offer some concrete evidence
that what you're saying is true.
That you really are different,
that there are customers
who have looked at what
you're doing and said wow,
that's amazing stuff.
Let's do that instead
of that other stuff
that we used to use.
So be clear, be compelling,
and be credible.
That's my advice
to entrepreneurs.
CORY: Yeah, that's
excellent advice.
So we talked about this
a little bit earlier,
we talked about technology
barriers are very low nowadays.
So the barrier to
entrepreneurship
is actually pretty low.
What, in the
technology space today,
whether it's virtual reality
or self-driving cars--
what excites you right now?
BILL REICHERT: Needless
to say, investors,
we get this question
all the time.
And I used to then start trying
to pick out the coolest thing I
saw last week.
And there's always
something incredibly cool
I saw last week.
But the answer is
in fact, pretty much
everything is
exciting right now.
So my phrase is
everything's trending.
It's not like there's anything
that's really out of favor.
Amazingly, gaming is still hot.
And apps are still hot.
But everything
else has opened up.
And so we're looking
at material science,
and what's going on there.
And that leads over into
this 3D printing thing.
And this is the company
I saw last week.
This eye-watering,
amazing technology
out of Lawrence Livermore that's
going to transform 3D printing.
Unbelievable stuff.
To all the stuff in artificial
intelligence, machine learning.
This artificial neuron
company that I saw,
that is building a neuron in a
chip that is 5,000 times faster
than a neural network computer.
5,000 times.
Amazing stuff!
So everything-- I
mean, I can't hardly
think of a sector that
isn't interesting right now.
Not to mention everything
Google has its fingers in.
You guys have your
fingers in, obviously,
in the virtual reality, and
in the autonomous vehicles,
and all this AI stuff,
and machine learning,
and everything in between.
It's an amazing time.
CORY: It's a very exciting time.
BILL REICHERT:
It's unbelievable.
CORY: Quantum on the horizon.
BILL REICHERT: Right.
Any day now we're going
to have quantum computing.
CORY: And that just
blows everything up.
BILL REICHERT: And
then now fusion.
Fusion?
Fusion's going to happen.
So it's an astonishing time.
Thanks to Google for stimulating
all this interest globally
around tapping into all
these opportunities.
CORY: And that's
really why we're
excited to be places like
here, with these really
interesting individuals
to be excited about.
So that's a good segue
into another question.
What is your favorite
Google technology?
BILL REICHERT: I mean,
there's so many things
that Google has permeated.
So obviously, Google
Search and Google Mail
just permeate our lives.
And so we don't even
think of them anymore.
It's like the fish in the water.
You don't know that you're in
water because Google is just
there.
Unless you travel to China.
And then you kind
of all of a sudden--
you're in China and you say,
well, let me just-- crap,
I can't.
Wow.
OK.
So that might have been
politically incorrect.
I don't know.
But I just love that
Google is willing to tackle
anything and everything.
I had the opportunity
to be over at Google X
and see the renewable energy
things that Google is doing,
and the Wi-Fi things
that Google is doing.
And those are very,
very cool technologies.
But I got to say, just this
last weekend I was particularly
enamoured of Google Photos.
Just the beautiful
simplicity with which
I can just upload that
massive, chaotic mess of photos
that I've got, and you
guys organize it for me.
Thank you.
CORY: Actually, that's one of
my favorite things as well.
BILL REICHERT: I
really appreciate that.
Yeah.
CORY: Well, thank you
very much for joining me.
BILL REICHERT: Well,
thank you so much.
It's been such a pleasure.
CORY: And thank you
guys for joining me.
My name is Cory on site at
Founder World in San Francisco.